in the previous episode parade ah ah ah
how's it going bimbos I mean rust ha ha
welcome back again to some more Conker's
Bad Fur Day I missed you bro
did you miss me I got a video coming up
with all the stuff I've been doing I
haven't been hello we're gonna keep
playing conquer
pretty much it's got before you gotta
love it money [ __ ] money only
sleeping man oh hell are you don't worry
my [ __ ] honey that's [ __ ] voice acting
ha this gate gets worse and worse by the
minute
oh poor conquer it doesn't even get
money whoa get that money that cash the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do here what
should I write beauty is that it well
what the [ __ ] okay ah right in my face
oh no no no no all right that was not
the correct Demento one now I'm I
suppose right penis
once was right open oh all right get the
pea get the pea [ __ ] get the
pay I got a pea in your momma's never
mind
BAM hey hey you why say was to a
[ __ ] was it well that's nothing
all right I got this there we go I am
get the end right away get down right
away
someone edit that out kids all right if
that one doesn't hit I lost my faith in
Jesus oh yay get me my damn money what
do I do now
of course you gotta wear whatever [ __ ]
that is and put that whatever [ __ ] what
honky cool your mama huh no way no yeah
that's owed of you I thought I'd die oh
well what do we do here what battery I
don't even more battery [ __ ] drunk or
some [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] here this is
phase-in let's just face my [ __ ] ass
oh I can do it
dick transformers dur dur dur dur
dodo good I don't know anything Oh
what's uh I think I'm in the right place
disgusting hey I nail that [ __ ] there
laughing what do we know hi yes right
quick put the top up yeah oh my god it
just
oh this [ __ ] game is so dumb just
showing up your ass
Oh what the [ __ ] I can't get drunk yeah
best game ever if you're getting a
dragon
I feel good oh wow this game is so
[ __ ] awesome okay hey what's up oh
they don't mind you if you're drunk
no no no dude sober goat summer don't
some bug eat the chocolate it's so
[ __ ] hard to control what the [ __ ] am
i doing
come on yeah I'm Jake email be follow
them up
oh wait a cat [ __ ] you my smell ah
that's gave it ha ha ha ha come here
little [ __ ] go back oh [ __ ] I can't pee
anymore
oh [ __ ] it's getting hungover now what
is this an aspirin and those never help
oh wait I talking about wine I keep
pausing oh I gotta [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
i'ma [ __ ] you betcha top I'm never I
never might I'm sorry [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] come on what the [ __ ] are you
doing
how do I pee I want to pee okay I got a
drink again
I gotta go drinking again I got it I got
it there we go uh everyone else that how
you doing
I think there's like some drugs in his
alcohol I don't know how you can become
like that yeah alright how the [ __ ] do I
pee on them come here [ __ ] Josh say
hello to my little friend
I made my big friend come back hey Dutch
yeah yeah that's right winking I'm
[ __ ] or Kelly come here that's right
you can all have some I'm getting died
come here
alright so apparently I'm just supposed
to pee on these people I did get that um
have you ever been drunk yes know how
you see a drug a lot just like conquer
stumped I don't do it I just still drink
but I don't get I don't get that drunk
anymore just like conquer does it I used
to pee on people and it was just awesome
I probably have to yawn someone I want
to be fine do I drink that [ __ ] no why
did you stop paying right away guy get a
big guy they're gonna make themselves
enjoyable guy
right was it peace are they talking
about their dead judge kudos judgment do
gone down we have businesses and uh-huh
he can't really Pompey
good Simon nothing yeah let me show you
some [ __ ] up working there yes the one
with it yeah oh I feel a me balls of the
Prosser bullish trend degree by watching
okay we'll go out okay [ __ ] boiler a
that time what are you gay conquer
whatever alright I got I got a oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] killed me oh yeah I forgot
you can charge your jump or whatever to
me jump our higher there we go
that's [ __ ] easy whoa of course the
only way to get light on opposite of
lighting what is that ignite no wait
shut shut up kela fires with [ __ ] and
diarrhea this [ __ ] game just gets
worse [ __ ] but in a good way in a good
way
hey you little [ __ ] area but the [ __ ]
you have to peel you I'm right here come
on
I'm right here there we go change that
step advance hey on bag hey on me I
never thought I'd said that good though
no better golden chance now conquer new
weird yeah so [ __ ] gross yeah alright
that was that one let's do this what did
he lose my sight again I feel like I
should do something with his balls I
feel like I lost something about it bulb
Here I am launching another I'm yours
that's a poet I copy right now all right
let's get touching balls
this might forget a fried patties bone I
get it I get it
fry pan dodgeball man Oh
bezu Fache battle our second batch batch
oh that is [ __ ] cake man come here
mad shower him and [ __ ] and then squeeze
his balls what a great way to kill him
Fox like him what should we do with this
box bad huh yes I do it that's it
that is me you don't do that my move
alright let's do it again
okay whoa whoa calm your mouth man up
luck it's very easy to spot but it's fun
so whatever [ __ ] metal balls
ah she had one more one more
my girls you get that boys girls you
will never understand
you've never understood what it's like
but you were never held a shadow much
like giving birth hey I give birth to a
lot of shits in my days I think I get
the point
all right dad don't try it I'm just
kidding I don't even know anymore
eat [ __ ] and die [ __ ] oh that's right
I got a squeeze y'all vodka man come
here give me those father's not yo geez
oh girl you don't do that sighs
highlight a novel da know the normal
door I never got it oh I don't think me
wearing all that weight back ah
we're company way out
what's this Mountain Dew money one loans
the smartest one you gotta go through
the back door
okay that's better than the back door
man why don't we have more games like
this this is so [ __ ] awesome am I
supposed to use the balls I am supposed
to Istanbul
wait we first year old ball
I mean ball up oh I should make him roll
next well bulk action on let me roll
boss if I wanna roll balls I should roll
balls oh okay we put it here probably
where what the [ __ ] that was the wrong
one I think what the hell is he doing
egg balls [ __ ]
hey best game ever worst game ever
director no bras oh [ __ ] oh we get the
money now that [ __ ] took forever yes
you did it brother
you want some great stuff yes [ __ ]
hell yeah yeah - right we did it all
right
great great job great job great day we
solved a lot of puzzles and finally we
get the money that was a lot of work
give it my company you want your money
or you want your money
hmm what a dollar yes yes No
ten percent Ashley agreed [ __ ] that one
two three ten can stop yeah I'm solid
I [ __ ] you study [ __ ] you come on I'll
tell you what here's a new deal I keep
the lot yeah hahaha
no it's not my money now [ __ ]
oh um load it you're gonna get a [ __ ]
it for now I think it's time room off
turn on your medica Tallyho
alright we got the money bras laughing
hope you enjoy this episode my baby's
dead can I have some come a bit of
tonight it's really fairly cool and now
see you tomorrow down from it I start
being creative it hosts a lot of trouble
for me but despite all of it I had some
of my best memories
approaching the end of my teenage years
I started to break out of my bubble
I took a final attempt to fix my grades
in school and I wanted to prove to
myself that I wasn't really ready